bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono la vj agissimo suster se devo
ripartire perché già ecco la partenza
della della storia ragazzino già partiti
bellissimi fatemi capire un atti come ci
siano finiti qua però ci sono dei
televisori a cazzo dovrebbe essere un
negozio di televisori di antiquariato
forza comunque ragazzi siamo in ci sono
delle puoi fare gli sprint con shift ci
sono scalia e basten sto gioco cioè va
bene che si chiama steurs però ecco per
fare almeno web
salve sono fa vj sono smau nato su delle
scale a cazzo se avete voglia di
spiegare chi è che ha buttato giù la
porta si bussa ai ragazzi volevo dirlo a
batista cagata nella porta che è che che
cade prova burley
salve sono morti di asfissia non so il
codice ragazzi non è che io tiro testata
le porte alle sfascio come voi e vedo di
fare il giro trovare il codice perché va
bene sole forte sfasciati sto posto non
ho capito ma cosa non cesso ma lo scopo
visto gioco a parte quello di trovare
porte sfondate cela uno scopo verona
perché i ragazzi non so dove sto andando
ma c'è puoi attivare la camera c'è una
videocamera davvero mica me la devo
costruire sta cazzo di caricare manco
gli ingegneri a sé cosa dica se mi
compra una reflex sarà più semplice
altri 20 del col destro ma che figura
ovviamente vado in giro cose belle
maniche perché si muove il muro
i nodi abbassare leggermente il flash
non perché se fai la foto una persona si
squaglia secondo regalo che hanno chiuso
la porta io me ne vado dalle palle il
prima possibile grazie comunque ragazzi
c'è la macchina fotografica che squaglia
le cose cioè non vorrei dire ma è
un'arma letale tesoro selphy no perché
veramente squaglio le persone o una
macchina gli faccio il culo vi giuro le
metto su facebook queste foto almeno
qualcosa sa qualcosa servono a dire che
non ho capito dove sto andando un
problema questo che cazzo siamo lega
sono sono dentro di nuovo dove cazzo
siamo notoriamente sono arrivato non so
dove bene non ho capito che interagisce
vole porte premendo è permesso io ho una
card devo vendere questa cosa sui bei
mela comprate voi facciamo prima la cosa
più bella visto gioco in assoluto è la
il sonoro rega chami mi riempie il cuore
di mortacci tua madra c'è qualcuno che
ha scoraggiato non si sa dove però visto
preso leggermente un colpo è amico mio
al natale è passato da un pezzo ma ok
capra in lattina da un sede ho sentito
qualcuno correre lega non mi prendete
per il culo se mi spunta qualcuno giuro
che uso la mia arma segreta che sarebbe
tipo questa ragazzi sta attraversando
dei posti sempre più macabri la cosa non
mi sta piacendo per niente ma che cazzo
è successo ragazzi è cascato qualcosa
non so cosa di preciso ma sentito il
rumore bruttissimo perfetto i ragazzi
security certamente il cielo c'è la
stanza questa davis tra nella stanza
nella sicura ma veramente ti giuro che
non l'avrei mai detto amica la passione
per le porte faccio la fotona ok
perfetto lamento pure su facebook che
non si sa ma 4 0 437 sera è stata una
roba di hackeraggio estremo e ragazzi
però ci siamo riusciti e 521 poi se c'è
o delle gambe
io delle gambe e delle braccia non ci
posso credere comunque ragazzo artista
rock ma sti cazzi la mano davanti non la
metti non so se devi votare liberamente
di melo e fratello comunque non è bello
sto posto a vedersi così no seriamente
ragazzi che cazzo sondando è troppo in
basso sta roba giornali supplico ci sono
le porte staccate ma che cazzate le
monache stacca le porte le pro gialli
vabbè io devo capire queste cose sono
veramente andiamo avanti così in eterno
di qua inutile non c'è niente qui dentro
si ho capito ma cosa mi serve cioè mi
hai fatto fare sto giro per st cagata
non c'è niente cosa devo fare spiegato e
hanno paparazzato a minchia e la
security rom quella lì devo vedere che
cos'è successo si è successo
devo andare a scoprire no noi non vado
non vado manco per il pene nella
security roma ok devo tornare nella
secchioni di rom perché qualcuno ha
fatto una foto e me l'ha inviata su
whatsapp non me ne frego nas è bello che
sia ma che dici di fare un po di make up
on a guardare iniziati faccio le foto ed
i tag oppure se viene concesso
dove vado non mi son perso dove tornare
perfetta ragazzi chiesta va
sta diventando un gioco per drogati
ragazzi non ne fossi ancora qui come
cazzo fatto finire di nuovo qua cielo
c'era un fascicolo prima con sopra non
c'è più perfetto se l'è [ __ ] quel
tizio mi sto pagando in mano chi era
quel tipo di prima che non ho capito se
ti fai vedere di nuovo la seduta degli
alcolisti anonimi ciao mi chiamo lorenzo
ho 19 anni e non bevo da dieci minuti
non ho capito così brutto come lo dovrei
chiamare ma facciamo anche lo chiamo
james perché mi sta molto simpatico no
seriamente perché il james emesso giuste
sedi qui c'è chi è che ha messo nei
secchi e che ha messo le sedi in cerchio
fatemi capire dovrei tornare nella
security room se riuscissi mike james
jones e sei tu che sei tu che esposti le
sedie james via via via via perfetto di
a via vivere le sedie iniziano a farmi
paura ragazzi muoviamo il culo che è
meglio perche ti apri ragazzi state per
assistere ad una scena epica sedie che
stuprano un uomo una cosa bellissima
si è aperta la strada tipo mosè la fate
passare l'uomo bello magari faccio anche
una foto a tutta vita vi cargo poi tutte
però non rompete i [ __ ] perché non
noi abbiamo visto non di video via via
veloci via veloci grazie dove c'è ancora
ma basta sempre qui a james tesoro sei
tu per caso c'è il sito che cos'è fermi
che io mica quando ci sono buchi nel
soffitto mica gohardacht sentite cos'è
successo di mortacci tua casa kia
caudino chi cazzo mi ha ruotato nelle
cuffie qualcuno mi ha appena rubato
nelle cuffie non ho capito chi sia via
via via via meno veloce subito se esco
di qua ringrazi dio si chiude la porta
mi ammazzo di botte non si è chiusa
ringraziando iddio non si è chiusa sono
tornato nella security this must be the
security ho capito che se non sei defici
a eco perfetto c'è un buco non aveva
richiesto il servizio trapano qui è
quindi non è che fate buchi così a casa
e poi vi chiedo i danni
stanno ancora facendo i lavori miss a me
e credo che sia lo stesso buco che avevo
fatto io a scuola per fuggire dalla mia
classe più o meno era più lungo però il
mira a son tornato nelle gallerie bello
perfetto che sento gente che maneggia
pezzi di metallo muoviamo il culo via
via via via via via via via cos'era cosa
appena sentito di brutti non ne ho idea
ma non mi volto manco se mi pagano in
oro
mi son volta non ce l'hai con me porta
perché io non so
via di qui subito veloce veloce veloce
apri apri apri ciao ciao ciao
ringraziando iddio so scegliere i muri
perché poteva essere un problema
perfetto via di noi siamo non si è
lavato le mani non schierava tre mani
usa il sapone
cosa è successo è finito grazie a dio è
finito così da una parte sono contento
dall'altra un po meno ma preferisco così
grazie per aver giocato a questa demo
tecnica grazie al cazzo è stato
divertente finché jackson ha iniziato a
spostarsi di è però concluso fine
episodio di serse è stato bello
i ragazzi servizio è piaciuto ma se il
sottomento mi piace anche la pace di
facebook e come video tratta la
descrizione se vorresti dissidente ci
vediamo non prossimo vinto dai ragazzi